[Music]
so as an entrepreneur as a Ted and TEDx
speaker as an award-winning author and
as someone who has named us a today's
most connected millennial a lot of
people ask me how I have built my
network and how I connect with people
and so I'll give you the high level and
then I'll go into maybe a few specifics
that you can use today to build a
world-class network in record time at a
high level I would think about
networking in in three basic steps step
one which shouldn't even have to be told
or shared is that you should be a good
person in the whole process of building
your relationship which is probably easy
at first you you bump into someone at a
coffee shop or at an event obviously you
want to treat them with respect treat
them like you would treat your mom is
something I was told recently that I
really like and shows like the level of
respect that you should have for someone
regardless of who they look like or who
they are anything like that just treat
everyone the same be a good person and
if you're if you're coming at it being a
good person instead of being selfish or
trying to win a quick contract over
someone I think you'll have a much
better job long term in terms of
building your network and as you become
a super connector you're gonna want to
be more intentional about how you spend
your time and so there's gonna be more
people reaching out to you trying to
connect with you and it's important to
treat them respectfully and be a good
person with maybe someone who is less
knowledgeable than you reaching out even
if you can't spend a lot of time with
them there's a respectful way to say no
or there's a respectful way to talk to
anyone regardless of if you end up
spending time with them or not so step
one be a good person step two is to
provide value upfront as you are
building friendships connecting with
people it's important to ask about what
they care about and what they're working
on and what's keeping them up at night
see if you can offer connections or
offer time or resources in order to move
their agenda forward and this is the
same in marketing you want to offer a
potential customer value before you try
and ask them for money or ask them for
value in return it's the same with sales
you have to build rapport and really
establish a relationship
but it's important with mentors as well
because a lot of times if you're
reaching out to find a mentor or you're
reaching out to someone important in
your industry they're fielding a lot of
the same sort of requests from other
individuals who want their time and want
their expertise and so you could stand
out by looking to offer value to them
and actually being proactive about what
it is they're working on for example
I've reached out to New York Times
bestselling authors right before they're
about to come out with another book and
so I know that they are looking for
introductions to press I know that they
are really busy and so anything I can do
to help them advance the book that
they're working on or save them time is
really valuable to them and so I would
think about you know always being a good
person providing value upfront and then
number three is being intentional about
who you're trying to build relationships
with that level of intentionality I
think is missing for a lot of us in
today's day and age there's so much
noise coming at us and so many pings
coming through our smartphone but if
you're looking to build a world-class
network and do it in a short amount of
time then you have to be intentional
about what types of people you want in
your network who you want to learn from
and how you're going to give yourself
access to different networks and so for
me I like to spend as much time as
possible with people that are super
connectors meaning they are
well-regarded in their industry they
have high integrity and they're also a
hub or an access point to a bunch of
other people in their industry and so I
know you know two or three Olympians and
if I ever had a reason to reach out to
more Olympians I would go through those
two or three individuals but I was a
good person and meeting them I provided
them value upfront and now you know I
have a friendship with them that allows
me access to a bunch of other Olympians
and same with the world of authors same
with a lot of fortune 500 c-suite
executives I know they all know each
other and so if you can build a
relationship with people who are super
connectors they give you access to a lot
of other people in their network if and
when you need it and then even when you
could provide value to people in their
network and you know along the way
you've got to make sure you're a good
person and keep your reputation solid
so at a high level that's how I would go
about thinking about networking
relationship building
[Music]